in the united states of america an
historically bizarre series of events
has been unfolding
when the sitting president donald trump
helped to ferment public outrage with
false claims of election tampering
it led to a violent insurrection by
right-wing protesters who descended on
the us capital
resulting in destruction theft and
multiple deaths
those events took place on january 6th
2021
two days later twitter made the decision
to permanently ban trump from the social
media platform
with twitter safety writing we have
permanently suspended the account
due to the risk of further incitement of
violence while people online debated the
benefits and drawbacks of that decision
the house of representatives immediately
set to work on drafting up articles of
impeachment
and on january 13th 2021 trump became
the only president in united states
history to be impeached
twice in the midst of all that a
question arose if we can hypothetically
remove trump from office mere days
before he would be leaving anyway
what else can he be removed from the
answer as usual comes from twitter where
someone had the bright idea to propose
removing trump's brief cameo in home
alone 2 lost in new york
priorities right excuse me where's the
lobby
down the hall and to the left the idea
went one step further than just removing
trump from the movie
instead of just deleting the scene one
twitter user made the case for giving
young kevin an eerie vision of the
future calling for
a petition to digitally replace trump in
home alone 2
with 40 year old macaulay culkin mccarty
colkin star of the first two home alone
films
is very internet savvy he's collaborated
with multiple people in recent years to
create comedic content
much of which pokes fun at his most
famous role it's safe to say that the
former kevin mcallister still has a lot
of fun with home alone hot takes
naturally that means people can't feel
truly assured that donald trump should
be removed from home alone too
until the star himself gives his
blessing and guess who showed up to do
just that
can i help you it's me mccauley
after much discussion colkin weighed in
on the original tweet responding with
one simple word
sold but how did that surprise cameo in
home alone 2 even happen in the first
place it probably won't come as a
surprise to hear that donald trump was
more responsible than anyone else for
his brief cameo in home alone too
in an interview with insider home alone
director chris columbus
revealed the entire oddball story behind
trump's brief moment in the film
saying like most locations in new york
city you just pay a fee and you're
allowed to shoot in that location
we approached the plaza hotel which
trump owned at the time
because we wanted to shoot in the lobby
we couldn't rebuild the plaza on a
soundstage trump said okay
however in what also won't come as a
surprise to many trump's go ahead came
with a somewhat self-centered catch
columbus went on to say we paid the fee
but he also said the only way you can
use the plaza is if i'm in the movie
so we agreed to put him in the movie and
when we screened it for the first time
the oddest thing happened
people cheered when trump showed up on
screen so i said to my editor
leave him in the movie that's a moment
for the audience but he did bully his
way into the movie
so what are the chances that disney
actually would digitally remove trump
and replace him with an older macaulay
culkin the home alone franchise is a
[ __ ] property
which means it's also now a disney
property and if there's one thing we
know about disney plus
it's that the people behind the platform
don't mind editing old movies to include
weird stuff
the classic tom hanks mermaid comedy
splash for example
has a scene where daryl hannah's burt
has been digitally hidden by cgi hair as
she runs toward the ocean
suffice to say there was no such cgi in
the original film
as from icarly swapping home alone too
well the chances aren't great
but it's certainly worth noting that
trump's cameo was already cut from
canadian broadcast network
cbc's airing of home alone 2 as far back
as 2014
according to the guardian who knows
maybe next year we'll be watching this
christmas classic on disney plus with a
few seconds missing
merry christmas you filthy animal check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one